with university students heading back to
class tuesday the board of regents is
pushing for a vaccine mandate for them
now there's already one in place for
staff joe mohler was at today's meeting
where they voted to submit a letter
showing support for that mandate
you are not medical doctors there was
plenty of opposition during public
comment keep medical records private and
vaccination a choice university and
college presidents on the other hand
showed that the majority of students are
for a vaccine mandate brian sandoval
from the university of nevada reno
included i think i do speak for our
students faculty staff when i say that
we would fully support
a vaccine mandate unlv president keith
whitfield says most already have it it's
over 90 percent that our students are
actually vaccinated friday the nevada
system of higher education board of
regents voted 9-4 approving a letter
supporting a vaccine mandate for
students at universities and colleges
regent jason getty says those attending
the schools are for it all of the
student groups have asked us to put in
this mandate a mandate is already in
place for staff at higher education
institutions in august the state board
of health voted to implement a vaccine
mandate for students but in december the
legislative commission voted to not make
it permanent this just leads the big
question in my mind who has the
authority then some at the meeting
including regent kathy mcadoo were
confused about who can make the decision
for a mandate it was made clear during
the meeting that it is the board of
health that can implement it when and if
that will happen is still up in the air
today's vote and letters simply show
support for it i am a yes on that thank
you the motion passes joe muller live
local now
now a petition with nearly 4 000
signatures sponsored by the nevada
faculty alliance was also submitted to
the board of health showing they also
support the mandate according to the
board's website the next meeting is set
for march 4th